we're going to find out on sunday who
will be playing in the super bowl to be
played in tampa and good news for the
chiefs bad news for the bills patrick
mahomes clears the concussion protocol
and we know this because he was allowed
to say so himself once you're out of the
protocol you can talk to the media he
spoke to the media he is good to go now
he can wake up with a headache tomorrow
and as brett favre surmised a few days
ago it's not like he's going to raise
his hand and say i don't feel so good
that doesn't happen very often and when
you have the super bowl in your grasp
you're probably going to be inclined to
not say anything i'm not saying that's
right it's just human nature but shireen
this is huge for
the
the chiefs obviously
and the question i have how's the toe
because we've forgotten about that and
will it change in any way patrick
mahomes willingness to tuck the ball and
run knowing that he just had a
concussion last week
yeah mike we don't know how the toe is i
mean he was listed as limited all week
but he's listed with the toe and the
concussion so we don't know how how much
the toe played into that because the
concussion he was limited so would he
have been limited by the toe if he
didn't have the concussion that's what
we don't know so he blew it off andy
reid's blown it off he did say on monday
it really hurt but it had healed i find
that hard to believe that just four days
later that toe is suddenly healed i mean
we see players all the time with turf
toe who are out for weeks so it's going
to be really interesting i think to
watch early in this game and see how
patrick mahomes is moving on the field
can he get out of it can he escape can
he run had 36 yards the last time these
two teams played we know how good he is
with floating back in the pocket and
buying time buying time and then make it
throw down the field is he going to be
able to do that we're going to find that
out early in this game i think leslie
frazier is going to put pressure on him
early in this game to find out just
where he is if you get beat early then
you say okay he's good to go he got out
of that pressure and
ran or whatever he did and you know and
you know to maybe change your game plan
a little bit but i think they're going
to test him early mike
i watched that footage we were showing
very carefully there was no favoring of
that foot as we saw last week during the
game but also if you watch closely he
never opened it up that's the question
when you plant and push hard as you are
accelerating and running at top speed
what will happen to that toe it was very
very
careful and deliberate as he as he moved
in the video that we saw let's have
proof of clearing the concussion
protocol let's hear from the man himself
patrick holmes from earlier today
talking about where he currently stands
two days from the afc championship
i mean you want to be out there um but
you have to you have to go through the
protocol and you have to do everything
the right way i mean uh you look at it
long term as much as you look at it
short term and
with going to the doctors talking to all
the doctors and going through the
testing
we have the belief that that this will
be no lingering effects and i'll be able
to go out there and be myself and be who
i am every single week
so again great news for the chiefs and
look even if you're a bills fan you want
to go best on best you don't want to to
beat chad henny you want to beat patrick
mahomes and punch your ticket back to
the super bowl for the first time since
1993 because if you do that you go into
the super bowl with the confidence
necessary to win it the next week when
you beat the other team's absolute best
in a game like this i think it gives you
that lift that you can get it done the
next time around something that bills
fans and i suspect after
going 0 for 4
30 years ago
that if the bills do win
those fans are going to experience two
weeks of dread while they wait and wait
for what could be oh for five i suspect
because i may have gone through
something like that three years ago this
weekend thinking do i really do i really
want
two weeks
of worrying about owen iv becoming owen
5. so be careful what you wish for bills
fans because you could be a long couple
of weeks and on the back end of the
super bowl and i know that's a loser's
mentality but i'm a loser
it's
owen 5 is worse than owen four
you don't want that 015 mike and you
know patrick mahomes has not had a
really really great game like we know
patrick mccombs has had since december
13th that's the last time he passed for
over 300 yards and he has eight
touchdowns and four interceptions in his
last four games he's probably due he
always plays well in the afc
championship game we've seen it over the
last two years he had three touchdowns
in each of those games and no
interceptions he steps up he plays his
best in the biggest game so if that tow
is is even close to a hundred percent
the bills are going to have their work
cut out for them to beat patrick mahomes
this
week hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports